je vais vous montrer le vêtement phare
de la saison qui fait quoi
mais on est sexy dance dance et la mini
jupe qui est fait en wax au motif
qu'elle tait depuis un an estelle facam
a lancé sa marque dunlop et compagnie
suite à l'engouement du wax un tissus
aux motifs traditionnels africains très
tendance depuis ces dernières années et
qu'elle a souhaité mettre en avant dans
ses créations
autre objectif promouvoir un
savoir-faire africains ont poteau
beaucoup logbox en afrique
mais en afrique il ya de vrais tissus
africains et la plupart des tissus
africains demandent vraiment un travail
d'artistes d'artisans parce que ce sont
des tissus tissé de fils de coton et
t'es à la main dans tous les
motifs que nous voyons pour les
désagréments sont réalisées à main levée
estelle fait venir directement ses
tissus de côte d'ivoire du sénégal et du
cameroun
c'est ensuite chez elle qu'elle les
transforme en jupe tuniques ou
accessoires
[Musique]
petit bandeau qui met bêtement ne
s'adresse pas forcément aux connaisseurs
parce que voilà c'est surtout à ceux qui
sont curieux qui veulent découvrir
d'autres façons de s'habiller et surtout
à ceux qui veulent un peu sorti de
l'ordinaire et apporter une pièce
originale à l'heure à leur tenue de tous
les jours comptez 35 euros pour une jupe
portefeuille une cinquantaine d'euros
pour un sac dans ses prochaines
collections estelle mettra également en
valeur des motifs indonésien pelvien et
colombiens